le live de chapultepec est mexicain et
vienne et chaque dimanche pour échapper
aux vapeurs d'essence particulièrement
lourd a mexico les descendants
d'espagnols et d'indiens se retrouve
ainsi au tour du lac qui fut le centre
de l'ancienne ville aztèque mexico
s'appelait tenochtitlan et elle a été
construite sur une lagune
et le mexicain de 1973 marque de
l'agacement quand il a l'impression que
pour l'étranger le mexique et ses
habitants semblent surtout appartenir au
passé
vous avez donné une vision
anthropologique des mexicains alors que
vous devriez savoir que le pays comptera
100 millions d'habitants dans 30 ans il
y en a la moitié en ce moment et 8
millions d'entre eux se retrouvent dans
une capitale où se côtoient les vieux
immeubles de l'époque coloniale la tour
américaine et la longue avenue réforme
qui traverse sa ville sur 37 km la
vitrine de mexico ces réformes réforme à
est aussi le mot le plus lourd de sens
pour les mexicains
révolutionnaire pour les uns contre
révolutionnaire pour les autres la
politique mexicaine s'est appuyé de tout
temps sur le sentiment national et sur
la réforme hier encore on florissait le
monument un benito juarez l'homme des
réformes un indien qui a lancé la
première évolution créole et libéral il
y a ainsi acteur
si juarez a été le précurseur des hommes
de 1910 ceux qui ont fait la révolution
agraire marcelino diaz lui a connu la
révolution il habite aujourd'hui igual à
dans l'état de guerrero marcelino dias
possède à un petit bout de champ et il
est heureux quand on lui demande à
mexicain pour vous qu'est ce que c'est
marcel hénaux il répond c'est d'abord un
paysan qui petit à petit a gagné son
morceau de terre sur la grande propriété
comme moi lannion
elle a une comme line aussi nkwenti dos
ça a commencé à mieux marcher à partir
de 1952 et puis le show se sont fait
progressivement on s'est partagé les
terres marcelino est né ici il fait
figure de privilégiés avec une dizaine
de vaches quelques à reprendre maïs qui
nourrissent il est vrai cinq familles
c'est-à-dire une trentaine de personnes
mes deux enfants de marcelino sont
partis à la ville à mexico
ici arrive certains jeunes pays blanc et
pourtant le gouvernement mexicain a fait
ces dernières années de gros efforts
pour éliminer ces gangs il vous deux
millions de jeunes vivent encore sans
travail
des drones a pas d'emploi fixe plus au
milieu de ses amis pedro n'a cessé de
nous répéter nous sommes pauvres c'est
vrai mais le mexique va se développer
peu à peu grâce notamment à son effort
technologique et nous ne sommes pas des
analphabètes ce qui nous manque ce qui
lui manque c'est la culture la culture
qu'on réserve aux riches mais nous
progresserons nous progressons peu à peu
la culture comment ne pourraient-elles
fasciné des jeunes mexicains même si
d'abord ils doivent penser à vampire
leur ventre 27 millions d'entre eux ont
moins de 20 ans plus d'un mexicain sur
deux donc et un sur cinq ne sait pas
encore lire sans que cela les empêche de
penser que la mexicanité cela existe
elle est là a mexico la mexicanité sur
la place des trois cultures aztèque
espagnol mexicaine enfin c'est ce qu'on
voit une tâche comme celle ci où les
trois textures la laisse une allure open
s'est enfin présentée par l'espagnol
l'indienne et puis la moderne de deux
ensembles le mélange des deux se
trouvent enfin ensemble on se sent très
bien parce qu'on voit quand même
le mexicain moder pour créer des choses
aussi belles que les autres
c'est le président et les verrières qui
a prophétisé 100 millions de mexicains
en l'an 2000 c'est à dire dans 27 en
autant d'années pendant lesquelles les
descendants des indiens et des espagnols
resteront partagé entre l'anthropologie
des touristes et la technologie de leurs
gouvernants